Now to this.
There are questions surrounding Senator
Dianne Feinstein
after her brief exchange
yesterday with reporters on the Hill.
The Democrat recently returned
after an extended absence
from Capitol Hill
recovering from shingles.
So a reporter asked the 89 year
old lawmaker
how she's been received by her colleagues
since she returned to Washington.
Let me read you the exchange.
It was not on camera but here it is,
verbatim quote.
What have I heard about what
she asked about your return?
The reporter replied,
I haven't been gone, she said.
You should.
I haven't been gone. I have been working.
You've been working from home.
Is that what you're saying?
The reporter asked.
No, I've been here.
I've been voting.
Please either know or don't know.
Close quote.
CNN has reached out
to find an office for comment.
No word back.
But joining us now is Benjamin Oreskes.
He is one of the reporters
that asked those questions.
He's a reporter
for The Los Angeles Times.
So you were there? We weren't there.
Is there a nuance missed in
what I just read
I mean.
No, I think that
given the ample amount of reporting
that we've seen in outlets
like my outlet,
San Francisco Chronicle,
the New Yorker about,
you know, her memory loss,
her struggles to keep up,
you know, an intense schedule
that a senator requires.
You know, we felt it was important
to put this out into the world.
You know, obviously,
there's a charitable
interpretation of this
and she's been back for a week.
Maybe she thought I was,
you know, talking about the last week.
But, you know, given
what has been reported
and had been reported
over the last couple of years,
it sort of seemed in line with that.
And, you know,
this is someone who
whose absence was felt
deeply by her colleagues,
partially because they're close to her
and also
because it made the work of government
more difficult and sort of
seen her in one of the brief moments
she's been pretty shielded
from reporters.
You know,
we were trying to show what she is
like right now.
We don't get a lot of opportunities
to hear her talk.
This was important for that reason.
Did her office
say anything
after this exchange happened?
Did they try to clarify
what she was saying?
Have you heard anything from them?
I know there's a short answer.
We reached out to them.
You know,
we told them what we were going to say.
We all have audio of it.
And, you know,
there were multiple staffers
with her at that moment
and they had nothing to say after,
you know, after we went to them.
Senator Blumenthal
has been a really vocal voice,
speaking in support of her
in her return, saying essentially
she's fully capable of doing her jobs.
I wonder if you're hearing the same
from the rest of her
Democratic colleagues in private.
It's a mix.
I mean, obviously, you know,
we have been reporting on this story
from D.C.
and from California,
where there's
an incredible amount of anxiety.
We have to remember, her seat is open
You know, people are three
people are running,
three prominent Democrats are running
it definitely from her colleagues in D.C.
They are confident that she can vote
and they're happy to have her back.
And they sort of
say she's the master of her own fate.
She's in control
of her own health decisions.
And if she feels like she's healthy,
she she should be here
Benjamin Oreskes, thank you very much.
And you said you have the audio, right,
so people could go
and listen for themselves.
Okay. Yeah.
All right.
We'll try to play that for people later.
Thank you very much for joining.
We have new audio
that we just got into CNN.
And it is from The L.A. Times.
It's an exchange between a few reporters
and Senator Dianne Feinstein,
the Democratic senator recently
returned to Capitol Hill
after an extended absence
that drew a lot of scrutiny and criticism
even from some of her colleagues
as she was recovering from shingles
Given the key role
she plays on the Senate
Judiciary Committee
and confirming judges,
a reporter asked the 89 year old lawmaker
how she's been received by her colleagues
since she got back to Washington.
This is what she said
What have you heard?
What have I heard about
what about your return,
how they felt about,
you know, why we haven't been gone.
Okay.
You should follow me.
I haven't been going. I've been working.
You've been working from
home, is what you're saying.
I've been here
I've been voting.
You know, we don't know, because
in our last hour, we spoke with the L.A.
Times reporter
that Senator Feinstein
was speaking with there.
He said that she was back for a week
at that point,
and that may have been
what she was referring to.
Of course,
it raised a lot of questions,
given she was gone for two
and a half months.
CNN has reached out
to Feinstein's office
for a comment on their version
of what happened in this exchange.
No word back yet.